I should've seen it coming.
It didn't take long after the fall of the Umbrella Corporation,...
...for their bioweapons to end up in the hands of terrorists.
A new era of bioterrorism descended upon vulnerable countries,...
...shifting the balance of power throughout the region.
People in the destabilized areas soon feared another incident like Raccoon City was inevitable.
As panic spread, governments of the world turned to the Global Pharmaceutical Consortium,...
...which formed the anti-terrorism unit BSAA.
Operatives of the BSAA were sent to infiltrate and neutralize bioterrorist hotspots,...
...restoring safety and stability to various regions around the globe.
Welcome to Africa.
My name is Sheva Alomar.
Chris Redfield.
Your reputation precedes you, Mr. Redfield. It's an honor.
Just Chris, thanks.
So you'll be accompanying me to the destination?
Yes. Tensions are running high ever since the change in government.
I'll bet. Intel says it's a haven for terrorists now.
And they're not going to be happy to see an American. BSAA or not.
That's why I'm your partner; help put them at ease.
I'm sure you'll do just fine. Partner.
You OK?
Yeah, sorry... it's nothing. Let's go.
Casualties continue to mount over the long years I've struggled.
More and more I find myself wondering if it's all worth fighting for.
Maybe one day I'll find out.
You don't have to get touchy.
Let's go.
There is one thing I do know.
I have a job to do and I'm gonna see it through.